[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance so new election our last one
was influenced by foreign power likely
coordinated with the victorious
presidential campaign influenced than
likely coordinated that is barring the
most extraordinary and unexpected
vindication one so sweeping that not
even Trump's most ardent supporters have
successfully hinted at it let alone
articulated it so new election obviously
it will be impossible ever to prove that
Russians cyberwarfare an internationally
managed disinformation campaign targeted
marketing that may have even been tied
to hacked and stolen voter registration
records and maybe even laundered money
caused the 70,000 Americans who decided
the Electoral College count to actually
vote the way they did and that they
would not have voted otherwise we cannot
examine the brains of every voter in
this country and Lord knows that with
the ones who voted for Trump we wouldn't
have much to examine anyway but the
mechanics of the interference and let's
call it what that was a Russian act of
war a virtual invasion of the United
States with the possible collaboration
and support of Americans who would be by
legal definition traitors to this
country the mechanics of how that war
was successfully waged against our
election and our freedoms and our way of
life that can be proved so new election
not only are those who oppose Donald
Trump getting closer to connecting every
link in that chain but each time he
opens his mouth or his Twitter accounts
about he was wire tapped and how his
campaign was spied upon
he is also connecting every link in that
chain
humpty-dumpty over there is simply so
focused on his unquenchable existential
need to make himself the victim that
he's begun to resemble the proverbial
defendant charged with killing his
parents who then complains he's being
persecuted even though he's an orphan
so new election there's no philosophical
construct in which were the Russian
conspiracy proved and Trump impeached
and removed from office that the
Republican Party should be rewarded with
continued control of the White House the
Republicans not only had ample
opportunity to derail Trump's Naumann
and even his victory in the electoral
college but he gave them a dozen reasons
and opportunities to do the right thing
they did not do the right thing to hell
with them so new election well we don't
do it that way we've had a presidential
vote of some kind every fourth years in
1788 we have held a presidential
election when nobody knew what the rules
were and only seven states had any
popular voting we have held a
presidential election while the British
were forming a blockade of our ports we
have held a presidential election in the
middle of a civil war every four years
you want a new election you will get it
in 2020 and none of that is explicitly
in the Constitution article 2 section 1
Clause 6 in case of the removal of the
president from office it is amazingly
vague it was later clarified by the 25th
amendment but the pertinent part is as
vague today as when the framers wrote it
quoting in case of the removal of the
president from office or of his death
resignation or inability to discharge
the powers and duties of the said office
the same shall devolve on the vice
president and the Congress may by law
provide for the case of removal death
resignation or inability both of the
president and vice president declaring
what officers shall then act as
president and such officers shall act
accordingly until the disability be
removed or a president shall be elected
until the disability be removed or a
president shall be elected not until the
term of the elected president shall
elapse the Constitution specifies that
an elected president serves for years in
the scenario in which the elected
president is out it specifies nothing
about how long the new president will
serve no every four years of an election
no serving out the term that's just the
custom and in fact the first time a
president did not make it to the end of
his term when William Henry Harrison
died after just 31 days in office in
1841 there were those who argued that
the vice president John Tyler should act
as caretaker in chief until a new
election could be held
now this was being debated Tyler simply
had himself sworn in as president
basically told his opponents to try to
do something about it that the Tyler
precedent as they call it is the
entirety of the reason that president
Mike Pence would presumably finish
Trump's turn or that president Paul Ryan
would presumably finish Trump's term if
Trump and pence were swallowed up by the
Russian scandal or or president Orrin
Hatch whose third in line or President
Rick's Tillerson whose fourth or
president Betsy DeVos whose 15th
president Betsy DeVos so new election a
new presidential election before 2020
might be constitutional though
presumably politically impossible
because some legislation of some kind
would have to be passed by the Senate or
the house and presumably affirmed by the
Supreme Court and all three bodies of
course would also have to be hit by
lightning simultaneously to knock enough
patriotism and morality into the
Republicans who control them to get them
to actually hold a 2017 or 2018
presidential election however this could
still be opening Pandora's box like
turning off all the gravity if we
somehow were able to break the tradition
the Tyler precedent the industry into
which we have made politics and
government in this country could
conceivably start to generate a new
presidential election every six months
elect a president swear him in impeach
him and his successors pass legislation
for another new election lather rinse
repeat
I mean imagine what the Republicans
would do with this well of course we
already kind of know if a Democratic
president had been elected as part of a
secret Russian war against this country
the Republicans would impeach that
president and the vice president and
everybody on the Democratic chain of
succession and embrace the cry of new
elections now rising from the streets
Wall Street and K Street specifically
hell in 1998 Newt Gingrich reportedly
had dreams that he would impeach and
remove Bill Clinton then President Al
Gore would pardon Clinton and then
Gingrich could then impeach Gore for
pardoning Clinton that would have made
the Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich
president instead of what he is now a
guy whose last presidential campaign
defaulted on debts of
four million six hundred thousand
dollars you missed the sunrise today
because somebody put something in your
drink last night
you can't go back in time to see it and
you can't declare there's going to be a
second sunrise at 4:00 p.m. you have to
wait but you do not have to wait three
and a half years so new election you
would be unprecedented and dangerous and
unprecedented and dangerous is where we
are now with this disloyal Punk in the
White House plus to me we should keep a
new election on the table despite the
risk and more obviously despite the near
impossibility that it would be
politically however if you want a
guaranteed new election to take the
government out of the hands of these
thugs if you want after Trump's removal
to keep our freedoms safe from the
fourteenth in line to succeed him that
would be President Rick Perry who would
serve just before President Betsy DeVos
if you want a new election for sure you
have a bunch of them this November I
don't care if it's the two state
governorships up for grabs in the fall
or the meril T's in 21 different cities
or balloting for the head of whoever in
your city government supervises the
Visiting Nurse Association throw the
Republicans who profited from this and
they have all profited from this and
they all knew who they signed on with
throw them out and put their party out
of business this fall and next year in
the midterms concentrate on voting out
every single Republican from the House
and Senate in 2018 run them into the
ground so new election that's your new
election matter of fact that's also your
new sunrise resist piece